gabriel et j'ai un problème je ne peux
pas résister une femme
trouvez le gars vous observez 24 heures
sur 24
vos pass permet de jouer au chat et la
souris guerrière où les soirs je ne
parlerai jamais elle m'a giflé avec ces
niches on appelle ça comment toi et
giflé gifle en plein front gîte long je
dis non ça c'est bon on ne peut pas et
je venais ton toi ça ne va pas le
gabriel j'ai un problème je ne peux pas
résister une femme
tentant connaître des filles ouais j'en
connait enfin quelques ginko normale
depuis qu'on est rentré en france un peu
compliqué on a perdu tous les contacts
attention nous on a des copies notion on
en connaît en san francisco plein plein
la rolls clar hall et la grande la
grande vous l'appelez la grande d'accord
faut quand même de foot et les catadores
vous avez un agrandissement des
malfaçons francisco rappelle gabriel et
j'ai un problème je ne peux pas résister
une femme
allez les gars
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait ça dans l'oreille c'est un
émetteur récepteur un très bon test
j'ai déçu en ne la regarde pas quelle
est ta 34
concentre toi sur le petit chat tu
maintenant regarder l évolution madame
gabrielle et j'ai un problème je ne peux
pas résister une femme je bossais sur
des briques à moi septembre records ne
pas résister aux femmes c'est le
problème de 90% la population masculine
comment comptez vous gérer votre
relation avec moi plus pas vous le
cacher les jolie brune au regard
pétillant et enchaîner enchaîné mais
aussi pourquoi pas enchaîner poursuivi
alors on va mettre les choses au clair
déjà les hommes qui souffrent de votre
pathologie s'imagine toujours que toutes
les femmes veulent coucher avec eux et
puis sans vouloir vous vexer vous avez
un sourire un peu niais voilà celui là